the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely well
it's a great pleasure to welcome Richard
panic on the on the program on the into
the impossible podcast which is a
production of the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination at the university
of california san diego so rich i'm not
sure how familiar you are with a with
the center for human imagination but
it's sort of the place where you would
feel right at home because we really
explore the interstices between science
arts writing science fiction science
fact and really in many ways
all thanks to sort of the visionary
pathway set by our founding namesake mr.
arthur c clarke who was of course a
polymath who capable of exploring deep
deep conversations in the and they in
the you know predictions about the
future to actually creating scientific
concepts and obviously science science
fiction as well it's hard to believe
we're you know almost you know nineteen
years past the the 2001 Space Odyssey
which inspired many of us to think both
about space exploration and to and to
think about the universe around us but
so I like to begin first with a with a
question to you as someone who's written
many books ranging from books with your
with your co-author Temple Grandin all
the way to the books written by yourself
alone about about physics and
astrophysics in particular and gravity
and cosmology what inspires you as an
author as a writer to get into science
you're not a scientist by background
what inspired you to take that sort of
leap into very I think very you know
both neuroscience as well as in the
physical sciences what made you take
that leap and and were you scared at
first great question
yes I was scared at first as you said I
don't have a
background in science and an editor used
to approach me in the mid-90s about do
it I want to write a book about this or
a book about that she liked my mighty
writing I guess and I turned her down
several times even though I wanted to
write a book I just felt that there was
no you know there was no no match there
I mean I don't know if you remember the
Republican governor of New York George
Pataki but she asked me if I wanted to
go straight his memoir I was like no no
no okay did she and she asked me once if
I wanted to write a book about the
telescope and I was kind of like no no
no because I knew nothing about it I had
no background in science and I and she
said you know I said to her I said you
know the thought of researching a piece
of technology for seven years and five
hundred footnotes and she said no no
think of it as an essay take a month
that's why I took liván and I and I read
up on it and I and I thought oh this is
really about history and philosophy
that's fascinating and I can get the
college education I was too stupid to
enjoy to appreciate at the time and I
wouldn't have any of any college loans
either so that so that's how I got into
it and just it just you know it just
fell in my lap and I and I just haven't
looked back and that was you know that
was more than 20 years ago Wow and and
it's it's nice to know for you know for
Governor Cuomo that you might still be
available perhaps to help him go stray
the biography and perhaps if it didn't
work for Pataki who knows it could work
for Cuomo so I really enjoyed your book
you were kind enough to send it to me
for free and and you still owe me a
signature you're going to give it to me
so they mean person but I like it so
much I bought an audio book because I
wanted to hear sort of the narrative
story told because it's really an
adventure story and I like to just
unfold disclosure I like to point out to
my listeners when does it you know when
is it okay to buy a book in Kindle when
is it okay to buy a book an audio form
likely to be missing anything and and
and I think in this book there are no
illustrations so for those of us who
like to listen to audiobooks they won't
miss out on any and any illustrations as
some books have not all books have to
have it and and it it really is an
adventure story so I think it lends
itself off you know to Kindle but but
certainly to the audiobook format that I
listened to it in originally and then
went back to read over several passages
in the hardcover so it's and my style
when I talk to authors associate
yourself I don't like to really talk too
much about the book itself I don't like
it when authors are forced to divulge
the contents of the book and and really
undercut you know what is our bread and
butter how we make our living for some
of us right so we'll talk about some of
the themes of the book but I want
listeners to really get into it the one
thing I do want to point out is I love
the the organization of the book it's
very logically
structured and what I like about it is
that each of the of the chapters begins
with the word gravity and and the you
know it's really the overall though the
subject is the trouble with gravity I
thought it was sort of in some sense you
know a natural sequel if you will to the
4% universe which you wrote back in 2011
in that that book is about the 4% of the
universe that we're sort of familiar
with namely the protons neutrons you
know croutons that we are all made of
some more than others and in the case of
gravity gravity has this mysterious
nature which it interacts as you
describe in a visceral physical sense
you want me your chapters is gravity in
our bones very evocative
and in the nature of how we encounter
gravity but it is a mysterious not it's
immaterial it's the force of gravity is
immaterial and you describe the latest
current thinking on it and Leslie
readers be left both you know really not
well I would say not warned not
forewarned we really don't come away
with an answer as to what is gravity and
I think that's what's so great about the
book in its title it's not saying what
is gravity what there are a lot of books
out about you know what is the nature of
reality what is you know what is the
nature of the origin of the universe and
I think fundamentally the question that
I grappled with continue to read
book and the honesty is very refreshing
that we don't know and even the greatest
minds that what made them so great like
Einstein as you described it what made
him so great is that he knew what he did
not know and he knew he got close to
things they delighted him they gave him
the greatest thrills of his life as he
said but he still didn't have a notion
of the essence I want to ask you after
writing the 4% universe and after
writing the trouble with gravity do you
feel like all of science is basically
unknown and and and that we don't really
have a visceral will never have the
visceral sense that our classical minds
want to have or did you come away with
the with the hope that perhaps we could
understand one of the four forces or
some of the aspects of physics or
cosmology and actually have a true
understanding that we would say we
understand it do you think that that
that's something you come away with or
do you think it still as great a mystery
as ever both both matter and and and
energy in the form and then and gravity
well first of all I went back to what
you were saying about the book being
upfront about that we don't know what
gravity is and that was important to me
and I put it in the introduction so that
readers wouldn't keep going through and
saying okay now we're gonna find out and
and I love that and this is also a way
to answering your major question I love
the idea of not knowing things so I was
very attracted to dark matter and dark
energy and 4% universe because it just
blew my mind that yeah we didn't know
what most of the universe was made of
and that all the Astronomy we've been
doing forever was based on an incorrect
assumption a natural assumption but an
incorrect one and then when I realized
that we don't know what gravity is I
thought well there's something there too
because we don't we just you know we
take it for granted and and you know and
with good reason they're you know with
good reason we thought that astronomy
was the was the science of the visible
universe because what else were we gonna
think and in the same thing with with
gravity and and I found a lot in
researching the book that when I already
tell people
you know we don't know what gravity is
people who aren't scientists would say
well what do you mean we do know what it
is if I let go of this thing it'll fall
so on and but when I would say to
physicists they would say yeah that's
right we don't know what it is and I and
I just loved it that that disconnect you
know between what our common assumptions
are and what what's really out there so
do I do I think you're asking do I think
that were that we're ever going to know
what dark matter dark energy and and
gravity are is that your questions yeah
do you think we're all like well there
is a hope for that I mean I guess
there's always a hope but is there a
chance that we would understand it well
I think there's probably a better chance
with with dark matter if if they
discover for instance the axe yeah which
is one of the candidate hypothetical
particles if they discover that then
okay we know what dark matter is dark
energy is a different kind of beast it's
it doesn't it doesn't match with quantum
mechanics it's one of those areas where
general relativity and quantum mechanics
don't meet so that's much more
challenging and gravity you know I guess
it's it's kind of contingent and whether
they find the quantum equivalent again
we're into the quantum world they find
the quantum equivalent particle which
you know has been provisionally called
called the graviton
but it you know it hasn't it hasn't
fallen out of the observations at at the
Large Hadron Collider for instance yeah
yeah I had a conversation a few weeks
ago I'm a into the impossible podcast
with dr. Sean Carroll of Caltech of
course has a recent book called
something something deeply hidden which
is also a quote from Albert Einstein
about the nature of reality and
so-called many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics and listeners can find
links to that on our various web sites
places where we you'll find our podcast
but but ultimately what Sean is taking
the approach of is is really not trying
to take gravity and quantize it as we
did with electromagnetism
really fine you know find gravity within
quantum mechanics itself so find the
origin of what we perceive as
gravitational force and gravitational
energy and so forth associated with
gravitational properties by looking at
the nature the fundamental nature of
what quantum mechanics is and how and
how we are able to really in some sense
in his interpretation you know find find
venues or are aspects of entropy of
connections to you know black hole
physics etc that really could cause
gravity to emerge from quantum mechanics
rather than the other way around so it's
not at all clear to people like Shawn
and I'm agnostic on this but it's not
all clear to people like Shawn like as
if we if we will ever be able to
quantize it but I guess getting back to
my earlier question which you which you
mostly answered but you know in part
it's let's say we do quantize gravity
and we have a good good explanation for
we have a good quantum theory of
electrodynamics in fact that's called
quantum electrodynamics and in some
sense it's the paradigm for all
different attempts to quantize the
forces of nature and the other three
forces you have quantum field theory
descriptions but but would you say in
your opinion I mean do we really
understand them because we can say there
is a photon do we do we understand
electromagnetism even more I recall a
story that Richard Fineman told and one
of his you know he's the only guy I know
can write in multiple autobiographies
but and one of them he said he you know
after he won the Nobel Prize for a QED
quantum electrodynamics you talked to
his father who's just a simple you know
a scientifically literate but not an
expert there in New York not far from
wherever you are I believe and he said
to his father said to him so son you
know now you won the Nobel Prize and
everything you know can you explain
something to me when an electron makes a
transition from a higher energy orbital
to a lower energy orbital it emits a
photon and firemen said that's right and
then his dad said something to the
effect of so was the photons stored
inside the electron all this time and
firemen said I didn't know and I said I
didn't know and and his dad looked at
him with
of dismay and disapproval and
disappointment the likes of which he had
never seen you know it held his son up
as his great genie they couldn't answer
the most simple quite so are we destined
always to really lack the the either the
linguistic skills or or the ability as
humans are we asking the wrong question
to really say do we understand gravity
as is a big thesis of your book I'm glad
to hear you asking the question because
that's the kind of question I wanted
readers to come away from the book with
you know to be to be challenging these
fundamental you know these fundamental
questions to be asking them and
challenging the fundamental assumptions
and in reading the book I do feel like
you're you're and you have this I
haven't read all of your other books but
but I come away with a sense of you sort
of being a tour guide and literally in
the book and some of my favorite
episodes you take us to Italy you take
us around the world you take us into
these intimate conversations with
scientists and laypeople and even
historical figures going back in time
and imagining kind of conversations and
I see this as a torgan and I maybe was
thinking as I was coming away from the
book feeling that just like a tour guide
you can't make me understand Italian
just because you take me to you know the
coast of Italy but but you can give me
the flavor of it and I feel like you did
you do give the flavor not only of you
know kind of a tourist but even for a
professional such as myself who do
wrestle with it and you interview many
eminent eminent physicist in the book
what what does it really mean to
understand and what does it say it means
to know you act as this consonant tour
guide and I think that's what impels the
reader along in this journey and I think
you know just personally I don't want to
insert things into into your into your
words but but that we can't we want to
know but when we say we want to know
what we really mean is we want to have a
classical understanding of things like
we can't understand quantum mechanics
because we're not at the level of you
know ten to the minus thirteen you know
millimeters but similarly so we want to
have a classic and our classical
intuition fails us ironically gravity is
the theory perhaps we have the greatest
access to classical experimentation in
fact the way that you got into this
field or into
book was through doing an experiment in
gravity so to speak where you
encountered you encountered gravity we
normally think of it as the weakest
forces and you literally fell over in a
bookstore as we are recant as you
recount and that encounter with gravity
and in a bookstore I can't help but
think that those are you know I don't
think you hit your head I think I think
you you you this this this encounter
really impelled you to want to learn
more but I think ironically we have this
classical understanding of gravity that
couldn't be better as you talked about
look we don't need quantum gravity to
send an Apollo spacecraft or a Ryan
spacecraft to the moon so I think maybe
it's it's like a sean is saying you know
we're trying to get quantized gravity
but maybe we should looking for the you
know gravity within quantum mechanics
maybe we're trying to understand gravity
but we should look for you know the
gravitational understanding and our
experience of classical everyday life
niels bohr who wrote a lot about the
philosophy of science really I mean he
had several several collections of
essays out and over the years they got
progressively more philosophical and he
was he was of the opinion that we that
we that because we came of age
intellectually in a classical
environment our language and our brains
didn't develop to understand quantum
mechanics and so we we just might not be
able you know to go back to your
questions I can we understand it maybe
the answer is is no because that's just
not the way that that that we operate
and we don't have the language for it
did you encounter so you've written you
know again you're such an intellectually
peripatetic author and intellectual I
mean you've written this book with with
Temple Grandin who's one of the foremost
you know kind of public figures who is
who I believe she has autism or as a
been dealing with that so you wrote a
book called the autistic brain with her
and you know there I wonder if you came
across throughout the you know
explorations either in the 4% universe
or in the trouble with gravity
come across you know this this notion to
watch I my understanding which is very
limited of autism is that there is often
times of frustration and ability to
perceive the sense of self the the
theory of identity both by people who
have autism of other people's a theory
of others of self perception but also of
others to perceive them and I wonder in
your encounters at least with scientist
are there commonalities between you know
the two kind of very physics heavy books
or not not no there's no equations but
but but in terms of the phenomena that
you're describing and the autistic brain
are there commonalities between some of
the scientific characteristics of a
great scientist and and and folks like
temple and and others or other
commonalities in the way that they
interact with the world that you see or
am i off-base they're mad I mean you I
don't I don't think that I've
encountered among scientists I don't
think I've encountered it you know
spectrum you know whatever you want to
call autism being on the spectrum any
more than I encounter it in other fields
other parts of life I mean you know yeah
I mean you be you meet people and you go
okay yeah that's that's probably you
know that might explain some things but
but but no on the whole no sorry and in
the in the interest of you know kind of
understanding the process by which you
go through and writing your books so
this is so you wrote that book with with
temple temple grandin what does that
process like working with a co-author
versus working by yourself I have very
limited experience compared to you and I
think a lot of times our listeners are
interested in the creative process of
revealing either scientific or cultural
or creative pursuits hmm
what's it elicited you experience those
two different paths to writing books
well you know when I when I write about
science because I don't have a
background in science I use that
ignorant on my part to in a positive way
because I feel like if I can educate
myself about something
then I might be able to explain it to
the reader in such a way that the reader
might understand I mean that I would
have understood it before I started
thinking about whatever the topic is and
and I tell my students I want my writing
students I told him to think about
nonfiction as inviting the reader to
stand with you kind of shoulder to
shoulder and you go you know and you go
exploring together so in my own work I
see myself standing with the scientists
and asking really basic questions and
then you get answers and then it leads
you down more complicated pants and
that's the model that I try to follow in
my in my book and structuring the book
and so with temple the same principle
operated I felt like okay I'm going to
stand with her and understand this
whatever the process is and then and I
did you know research on my own and use
that as part of the narrative as well
you know researching the history of the
diagnosis for instance and you know
raising some again historical and
philosophical questions about that but
and and in those sections of the book I
mean that was me kind of you know
inviting the reader to stand along with
me but I got there by standing along
with temple just as I do with the some
of the you know the writers or the
scientists who I you know I mean
especially in the 4% universe which was
really a contemporary history of the
discovery of these two phenomena and as
well as the Cosmic Microwave Background
and just you know talking to the people
who did the work and saying okay walk me
through it what happened then what did
what were you thinking what did you want
to know what did you find out did that
surprise you what questions that are
raised and you know just by taking it
down to this really fundamental basic
level I find that you can
create a story out of these discoveries
and the same thing with temple excellent
thanks for that we'll come back just at
the very end to one creative question
that I like to ask all my ok on my
podcast guests but I want to talk a
little bit about not again I want folks
to read the book by the book by the many
copies makes a great depending on when
you hear this Martin Luther King jr. Day
present or Valentine's Day present or
maybe even New Year's Eva for quick
the trouble with gravity by Richard
panic who are interviewing today it's
gotten fabulous reviews Kirkus it was
selected as one of symmetry magazines
books of the year of 2019 which is which
is rather outstanding because everybody
else on the list is basically a
professional physicist or you know I
will
you know well experienced scientist who
was a popularizer of science so
congratulations on that thank you so in
the quest to understand gravity which
you pointed out something you know which
I always love to do little bits of
trivia and in my book you know one of
the things I hear the most about is I
didn't know that the word lense came
from the lentil beans Shing and and then
I thought about your book and and and
really not knowing that Newton you know
it was sort of coining this term gravity
in a sense that hadn't been coined
before and it has the connotation of the
grave right so one of the wonderful
things about the book is a historical
you know I called it you know in my in
my notes on the book you know a brief
history of gravity but it's not only
etymological it's it's sort of you know
ontological you're on you're exploring
how has it been been actually perceived
but but also how how has it been
experienced no III and I love the fact
that you start you really start from a
very heavily religious perspective you
talk a lot about you know the in the
context of Jesus and and even in the Old
Testament how is this experience and I
was curious cuz I don't know much I
heard an interview a podcast with you
not too long ago and I recall that you
were raised Catholic Big C I think
Catholic and so can you tell us more
about your
your pathway through faith and if that
did that have an influence that there's
a good you know chapter to that that
that deals with that not as an
overarching you know kind of overbearing
way I should say but really it's almost
a historical narrative of how how these
people conceived them what is up there
heaven hell Dante you know you're one of
the few writers who can bring up Dante
and then you know throw an always
popular cultural references so anyway
getting back to the original for our
first further question yeah dealing with
how is there this religion play a role
in this book or in your life personally
or no my life so so much
I'm a very lapsed Catholic I was raised
Catholic but long long last but but you
know certainly there is that influence
in made that curiosity about religion
what I found in researching the book is
that I started looking at creation myths
so I'm dealing when I'm when I'm dealing
with religion when I'm dealing with you
know Catholicism and things I'm still
looking at them for me in the context of
mythology what are the stories we tell
ourselves about about our relationship
to the universe and we do that through
sometimes through religion and mythology
and I started looking at creation myths
and I on my own I just kept reading them
thinking about how does this relate to
gravity because you use the phrase you
know up there and I used that heavily in
the book the difference between up there
and down here and that doesn't wouldn't
occur to us unless we were wedded to one
of those two areas and in researching
creation myths I found that in almost
every K actually in every case that I
can cross they they all begin with the
separation of earth and sky and it
dawned on me that there we wouldn't be
making that separation unless we
identified with one of those two areas
and we saw them as distinct and and then
the area up there is mister
so we give it special qualities and we
call them you know gods on the mounts or
in the clouds or whatever and and then
we attribute certain other qualities to
what is familiar to us and and and what
is mundane and mundane comes from the
Latin mandamus for of the earth there
honoring and and in the grave did you
say that yes yeah yeah yeah yes oh yes
oh so gravitas heaviness gravity they
all have the same associations so I
found it and then I came across a quote
from this scholar from the mid 20th
century who is I guess one of the one of
the leading Scholars on creation myths
and I quote this in the book he's yeah
who says that he calls that division
between sky and earth the primeval pair
and I thought wow okay so I it's like it
occurred to me and I pursued it in the
end and and eventually I found this
validation for this idea that I had so
so you can see how in the creation myths
the beginnings of religion it's already
it's already there how we see our
relationship to the universe is right
down here
and we acquired up there and also you
know I took away they you know this
connection is fun these these these
dichotomies that you start the book off
with I'll just read at the beginning
because it does start with the same in
the you know basic prologue as the most
famous book with the highest book sales
I always say I just want one percent of
God's book sales you say in the
beginning were the heavens and the earth
you can look it up then came light and
dark and with them day and night
soon followed the beasts of the earth
and the fowl of the air mmm what wasn't
in the beginning at least I'm explicitly
was whatever was creating this division
still that whatever was implicit in
those binary distinctions that whatever
defined with the exactness of a razor
the most fundamental divide of all the
her
The Horizon becomes a sort of character
but also this yeah the binary
dichotomies op down you know and then we
see you know sky earth and these in the
in the beginnings you know and then that
makes you think about the end right so
there are all these dichotomies
discussed in the book and I think it is
is sort of interesting we even have it
you know in our in popular language we
talk about you know falling in love and
what are these emotions are you talking
about those as well and on what's very
charming in the book is you don't you
don't shy away from really saying that
there wasn't relevancy I mean obviously
the Bible is not a science book but but
really you know by starting it off with
some sort of a note notion of foundation
of divisions up here down there it is
certainly inculcated a curiosity and
people and as you say in the book you
know if there was beginning this concept
of the end and what that meant to folks
like Dante and you know the end is it a
theological end is it a physical place
within the earth and then all the way up
through to the to the scientific
expletive
starting with with Galileo who plays a
huge role in your book as well as my
book and Newton who is a really
interesting character because he kind of
combined those religious and the
scientific sensibilities in a way that
you know few before him are after him
have but it's so interesting to look at
all the great characters that you think
about the greatest thinkers in history
and and and they all can they all you
know confronted gravity and and here we
are today still confronting it maybe
with more precise tests and I think it's
a wonderful way to think about it one of
the things that spoke to me as well was
that you mentioned not only the
scientific and cultural aspects of
gravity but the political aspects which
was sort of a surprise to me but then
you know reading the book you talked
about John Locke and and his influence
on the founding fathers of America I
don't know can you say a few words about
that that was a unique thesis that I had
not really heard explored before and I
want to come back to that after I hear
how did you find out about that what was
the what was what's the role that that
you know gravity plays and the founding
our country so to speak okay well about
20 years ago I had a book the telescope
book that I referred to earlier around
the telescope is called seeing and
believing and in researching that book I
saw that okay the invention of the
telescope which then galileo takes in
converts into a scientific instrument
and opens up you know all sorts of new
understandings of the universe that that
was the moment that was the first
instrument that extended one of the
human senses okay extends the sense of
sight and it again it put the ability to
investigate the universe into the hands
of the person who is doing the
investigating so it was in that sense it
was a democratic small D democratic
invention and that it it it removed or
transferred some of the power from the
distant king or Pope or God or whatever
and gave it to you because now you could
hold it in your hand and you could see
for yourself and you didn't have to take
somebody else's word for it and you
could repeat what other people saw so
this was you know it was the beginning
of the scientific method right in the
way that we think about science and and
then in researching the book on the
telescope I I saw that this democratic
principle then you know it did it just
it kind of laid out logically that if
you have this instrument in your hand
then you have more power and the power
shifts and it you know as I said and it
eventually leads to to to some of the
things that I quote in this book so I've
been thinking about this for you know
for a couple of decades and and it leads
to some of the you know the observations
in in this book where the founding the
founders of democracy were we're
thinking about you know what are the
implications of the scientific method
and
and how do we know you know are the
stories in the Bible which were assumed
to be literally true the New Testament
stories were they were they actually
true and I mentioned in the book that
Thomas Jefferson cut out he took the did
you testin of the Gospels in the New
Testament and he and he cut out all the
miracles and published that as as the
story of Jefferson Bible right so you
know this is very much on their on their
minds you know and and giving take you
know giving the power to the people
yeah so I I came across an interesting
connection to that as well over the over
the summer I forget what really prompted
it but I was looking at the works of
Euclid and throughout the works of
Euclid he talks about sort of certain
propositions being self-evident and in
other words I think I think there aren't
so many things in Euclidian geometry
that you can say are self-evident but
once he establishes some things he then
goes and says by extension you know if
this property halls this holds true by
axioms of logic you know that parallel
lines don't need or things like that and
and then later of course Newton in the
Principia picks that up as well and he
has the exact same language you know
basically copying from from Euclid and
says that such and such is self-evident
as well and then of course folks like
Thomas Jefferson you find the exact same
language coming into the Declaration of
Independence and and so forth and the
self-evident sharing nature of things
which is really you know not exactly you
know part and parcel the scientific
method all right you have to say well
that's self-evident because you know
some people that might not be you know
if you have a heavier object it seemed
self-evident
fourth millennia that they would fall
faster than than a than a lighter object
but of course that's not true I think
you know I had a question as I'm reading
in thinking about this conversation that
we're going to have so if it's true that
that things are self-evident and that's
a way to prove things or at least
motivate
assumptions being being provable then
you know and you talked about this in
the book how Einstein Tec Euclidean
geometry and really threw it away
and established well heat with with the
help of Lobachevsky and others geometers
which you recount sorry I didn't know
which is that he really didn't care so
much about Euclidean or non Euclidean
geometry early in his life and then it
became the basis of the theory of
general relativity first can you say
something about what does it mean non
Euclidean geometry and then I'll ask the
question about well if Euclid's wrong
and then you know anything really said
to be self-evident but first can you say
a little bit about Einstein and his
encounters with non Euclidean geometry
much will you you just mentioned the
Euclid's example of parallel lines
always made well and none Euclidean
geometry you can have a curved surface I
mean you know you look at a balloon or a
ball this has lines of longitude on that
lens of latitude on it and they meet at
the poles but they're parallel at the
equator right that's one example that's
not exactly what Einstein used it for
but yes right but he needed it we're
thinking about curvature in space
space-time and so so and that is the
sort of modern you know as we teach it
in our cosmology classes we talk about
different possibilities for the
so-called curvature of the universe
which would be manifest really only on
its largest possible scales I don't know
if you know but I wrote a book on
Einstein and Freud about 15 years ago
called the invisible century and it's
about how they change the way that we
see science and the way we think about
the invisible and or the non tangible
and and and so I I wrote a fair amount
about general relativity in there and
how you know how he how I know I needed
to incorporate non Euclidean geometry in
there but I can't pretend that I
understand it fully right I had to for
this book I had to really confront
general relativity in a different
you know much more rigorous way that was
difficult so one of the things that one
comes away with after reading the book
is that you know sort of the lay person
will assume that even if they don't know
what gravity is some scientist knows
what it is it seems like the greater the
scientists the more perplexed and
baffled they are with with gravity and
how to kind of reconcile it's it's you
know apparent simplicity
you know inverse square law is something
you can teach to you know fourth graders
but but that you know really
understanding its essence requires so
much more and and you make the point
repeatedly that the greater the
scientists sort of the greater their
acknowledgement of what they didn't know
up until the very day when you encounter
Kip Thorne so maybe you can relate that
story as well right so people on was one
of the people one of the one of the
people behind the LIGO experiment that
wound up detecting gravitational waves
so the for the first time prediction
that was kind of embedded in Einstein's
equations but nobody had observed them
and and and so Kip was one of the people
who put that experiment together that
took decades to get rolling and I asked
him once I was on the phone with them
for something unrelated to this and and
I just thought okay I'll ask him what
I'm asking everybody else so what is
gravity and and he said well that's a
meaningless question and that really
became part of the impetus for this book
I recounted that anecdote in the
introduction to the book the preface and
and I found myself thinking about that
question a lot as I wrote the book and
asking myself well what did I even mean
by that you know what do you mean by
what is this goes back to the to the
discussion we were having at the
beginning of this of this conversation
about you know how do you how do you
define things what what is the meaning
of something so I had to really think
hard about
I was but I must have thought I was
asking him yeah yeah yeah I was a
meaningless question but like a lot of
meaningless questions I mean seriously
Stephen Hawking was said to have said
you know asking what happened before the
Big Bang is as nonsensical as asking
what's north of the North Pole of course
every kid will tell you it's Santa Claus
but in reality the you know the the
notion of these very simple questions
that are simple to ask but you know
maybe impossible to answer I'm not sure
you know if I agree with Kip on that and
that note I think it's incredibly
meaningful it's just we may lack as I
said as we discussed earlier you know we
may lack the you know vocabulary and the
articulation to really underline it but
what is you know the detection of
gravitational waves if not the really
crowning achievement of a theory that
was predicted a hundred plus years ago
by Albert Einstein and the consequences
of which it took so long and so much
painstaking energy by Kipp and and the
team of over a thousand people on LIGO
and and is still going on to this very
day this quest to understand the
universe and see it in the same way that
the Galileo did of course as you point
out you know Galileo democratized the
telescope although he was pretty very
secretive about it he didn't actually
even allow Kepler to use the telescopes
that built himself because he wants to
keep his monopoly going and likewise I
don't think that they'll be you know
you'll be able to get a $25 LIGO replica
are not replicas an actual working LIGO
you know on Amazon anytime soon but but
but but you know we always talk about my
late colleague here UC San Diego
professor Hans Parr used to say that he
was a European a Dutchman worked with
Leon Lederman and others in discovering
many fundamental particles that we know
about today and and he said that you
know his opinion general relativity was
the culmination of Western civilization
and
you know really to understand it to
communicate it all the meta skills plus
all the actual physical skills and
actually going into the detection of
gravitational waves which are really the
last remaining piece of confirmation
needed to assert you know to prove to
the extent that you can prove a
scientific theory and I think it's it is
wonderful to think about well what do
people will do scientists do I think we
contribute to culture and so one of the
ways that I like to wrap up each podcast
that I have is to ask the guest that's a
question that is you know I've asked
this to literally probably fifty people
have been on the show and that's about
creativity because a lot of times we
don't think about we think about writers
we think about artists as creative and
actors and I don't that scientist is
creative and I wonder you know in your
profession you're not a scientist
professionally but I'd say you know
you've got pretty good street cred you
know after writing all these wonderful
books on science and and and instruments
of science and the personalities within
it you have way more than a laypersons
exposure to it but even outside of that
in your craft in your field you teach
writing and and and so forth but can you
teach creativity can you teach humans to
be imaginative as our center here UC San
Diego Center for human imagination is
named after Sir arthur c clarke is that
something that in europe union can you
teach creativity and if so how would you
go about doing so well you know the
course that I teach at Johns Hopkins I
was invited to give a talk there a few
years ago and after the talk the person
who's running the program came up and
asked if I would be interested in
designing of course and over the over
the years I've been teaching it out for
six or seven years in the spring
semester and it's called science as
narrative and I over the over the course
of teaching it I've found that the
scientific method and writing narrative
are very similar and that's and that's
really the major point of the class very
briefly the scientist and the narrator
basically asks three questions it is
what do I know what do I want to know
and what do I learn and what you learn
is usually some of what you wanted to
know but then there's a surprise in
there there's other information and then
you go back to the beginning say okay
now what do I know now what do I want to
learn etc and that's how writers keep
you engaged in a narrative throughout
the law think about a movie every second
of a movie is taking you a little bit
farther along and creating more
anticipation and part of the art of
writing is to create that curiosity in
the reader and create the anticipation
then rewarded but not quite not not all
the way until the end of of the project
and the same thing is true of scientists
they're asking themselves a question
what do I know what do I want to know
what do I learn and and so it is I think
a very creative endeavor because you're
trying to figure out how am I going to
get answers out of the universe and how
do I change my thinking so that I know
that I'm asking the right questions and
and being aware of when you get the
surprising answer and you know I mean
here we've been talking about dark
matter and dark energy neither of them
was predicted no dark gravity you know
we don't know what it is people aren't
aware of that you know again and again
there are the surprises in science and I
think that you need to have you know a
creative mind I mean I think that
Einstein wrote wrote about this a lot
that that we did you that that you need
to be able to have that intuition to be
able to see something I forget who who
it was I think it might have been
Faraday who saw an electrical event
occurring in his mind before he ran the
experiment yeah I mean Einstein with
is thought expand experiments right
right I mean answer yeah yeah I I was uh
I was talking with Adam riess recently
who won the Nobel for his participation
in the discovery of the evidence for
dark energy and and he was and he
started using a metaphor and I
remembered years ago I was at I
deliberately wanted to go behind the
scenes at a press conference and see how
the press conference is created how the
media created and and I went down to
into the to the Space Telescope Science
Institute in Baltimore and and I sat
with Adam before the beginning of the
press conference and he was trying to
describe something mean he was using he
was using him a metaphor and then during
the press conference which was a an
audio conference it was a dial-in
conference so there were just the people
from the Institute sitting around the
table and fielding these questions and
and so on
and Adam threw out a couple of metaphors
in the course of the discussion and as
soon as the press conference was over as
soon as they cut the audio everybody
talked about which metaphors worked it's
very much a creative endeavor indeed
yeah well I want to leave audiences with
that cliffhanger and I use that word
advisedly and those of you who read
Richards phenomenal book the trouble
with gravity well know why I left it
with that word cliffhanger
because actually every chapter really
impels you to read more and it's the
sign of a I explained and I explained
the origin the first time a cliff that's
what I'm hinting at but now it's it's
fine yeah I did delight in that
description as well Richard thank you so
much for sharing your time with us and
we'll let you know when this comes out
and it's been a pleasure talking to you
and I hope we can meet in person someday
so I can get
your signature on this hard copy thank
you thank you for sending your book with
the with a bit of galactic dust spinach
oh yes that's a piece of space dust
throttle oh by gravity yes that's right
exactly well thank you so much Richards
happy holidays happy 22:00 and looking
forward to talking to you again oh
thanks you too the only thing we can be
sure of about the future is it will be
absolutely
[Music]
you
you